the Paradox of liberalism is that the
Liberals who say that they are the most
independent thinkers in the world are
the least likely people to think for
themselves and this is not just some
cheap political shot that Aya
conservative and making about them Sam
Harris a leading public liberal is
telling you that's what liberalism says
Sam Harris is admitting that for most
people they cannot think for themselves
that's his view as a liberal that's not
my view as a conservative and if you
look at the liberals who insisted follow
fauci follow the EPA follow who follow
follow follow and you look at the tin
foil hat conservative conspiracy
theorist contrarians who's been more
right the conservatives the contrarians
the conspiracy theorists crazy tinfoil
hat people have been right statistically
100 of the time and those liberal
Geniuses following Sam Harris and the
rest of these
people have been wrong statistically one
hundred percent of the time